إنه ذلك الوقت من العام الذي
يبدأ فيه السعال الناري الذي يشعر به الناس تحت
جائحة الطقس في إصابة
الناس بشدة ، حان الوقت مرة أخرى للحديث
عن أهم شيء
نحتاجه لأن نفعله جميعًا كل عام
، وهو الحصول على التطعيم السنوي ضد الإنفلونزا.
الأنفلونزا
مرض تنفسي يصيب الأنف والحنجرة وفي
بعض الأحيان يمكن أن تكون أعراض الرئتين
مشابهة لنزلات البرد ولكنها تأتي بسرعة
وتشمل الحمى وآلام في العضلات أو الجسم والتهاب
الحلق والسعال ويمكن أن تكون التهابات السعال
خفيفة إلى شديدة وفي بعض الحالات مميتة
للأطفال الصغار والنساء الحوامل.  الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
حالات طبية مزمنة والأشخاص الذين
تزيد أعمارهم عن 65 عامًا هم الأكثر عرضة للإصابة
بمضاعفات متعلقة بالإنفلونزا ، توصي المراكز الأمريكية
لمكافحة الأمراض والوقاية منها
بتلقيح كل شخص يبلغ عمره ستة أشهر أو
أكثر كل عام ويفضل
بحلول نهاية شهر أكتوبر لموسم الإنفلونزا هذا.
تم إجراء تغييرات
على اللقاح الذي يتم تحديثه
ليطابق بشكل أفضل الفيروسات التي من المتوقع
أن تكون قوية هذا العام  والأهم من ذلك أنه
سيتم صياغته لمهاجمة أربعة
فيروسات مختلفة للدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا مارث وود